any questions mr griffin are you
seriously never going to teach us
biology at all
sure sereka maybe uh pablo picasso can
come in and teach driver's ed
guys i am a published harvard philosophy
professor i have no interest whatsoever
in teaching biology to you people
okay so drop it i love the philosopher
prabhat sarkar
the entire universe exists within the
cosmic mind
what are you guys doing don't write that
down that's not me teaching you stuff
according to this gossip column my
nemesis miles is
dating lisa loeb the lisa loeb songbird
sex in glasses meanwhile i have had
zero bangs since moving to this garbage
pile of a town
that's not gonna work for me so new plan
break up miles and lisa loeb
what the hell is going on here
it's parent teacher day
well welcome to ap bio yeah he's just
got a real turd of a personality yeah
but you two seem like a couple of wet
blankets as well
all right everybody let's go ahead and
start to shut up now
let's go ahead and uh start to settle
into your seats and uh begin shutting
your mouths
all right so my name
my name is jack griffin
and i don't want to be here i am an
award-winning philosophy scholar who for
reasons i won't go into finds himself
with a free year
so i'm living in my dead mom's apartment
here in toledo while killing a little
bit of time teaching
advanced placement biology but here's
the deal
i do not care about biology we're not
going to do any biology in here and to
be perfectly clear
this won't be one of those things where
over the course of a year i
secretly teach it to you this also won't
be one of those things where
i end up learning more from you than you
do for me
i know more than all of you combined so
that doesn't make any sense
i'm going to spend the majority of my
time mentally breaking my nemesis
with the ultimate goal of taking his job
as the head of stanford philosophy and
then i'm gonna have sex with as many
women as i possibly can
throughout the entire state of
california but
you don't need to concern yourselves
with that ah
see you might be forgetting something
mentally breaking my noses sex with
everyone in california no that was it
welcome to ap bio there's something
dangerous lurking inside of her
something edgy
i think you need to foster that yeah
guys get me my own pressure cooker
i want to make brisket and i want to
make it quick you're not old enough to
get a pressure cooker but i'm old enough
for an hpv vaccine
he's uh he's on his way i just texted
him
so did he text you back nope
nope all right everybody start to shut
up
ralph what brings you here you're late
i'm i'm covering for you
it's school policy you can't leave these
students unattended
is that a real rule that's nuts he
literally leaves us alone all the time
uh narc much zarika has no sense of
humor zero
does she laugh at anything zarika
refuses to have fun i think i want to be
spending five hours every saturday at
the academic decathlon no
no no i'd rather be poolside buns up
sipping a malibu
yeah that's what i thought
these damn textbooks should all take a
page from how cool dan decker is you're
not gonna see him thumbing through a
biology textbook
nobody gave me one yet nobody even gave
him one how cool is that
you know what line up with your books
over here come on line up with your
books let's go now you see all these
open windows
anybody want to guess what happens next
mr griffin we can't throw out our books
what about the ap
test oh can we not throw out the books
let's go toss em guys toss em
[Applause]
srika sarkar are you gonna be okay
not without my book no
how'd you know i didn't i didn't hand to
god i did not know
oh man i could really i could have
really hurt you whoa
oh man i have a 4.125 gpa never talk
about grades
no one cares they have no impact on life
next
feeling a little hangry huh no no no no
no that that is such an annoying word
don't don't do that okay back of the
class marcus are you serious yes i'm
serious go
now i just i can't i can't do it with
you today man
too hungry ugh nah that's not gonna work
turn your desk around
i can't i can't look at your face i just
can't
angry means horny and angry basically
you're so horny that you're angry
all right that's still not working for
me uh you see a leak right there trying
to get you under that leak all right get
your body under that leak not the desk
your body oh that's perfect
there we go now if none of you are
willing to share your snacks with me
then i guess i'm off to the vending
machine for a little dose of c13 cape
cod salt and vinegar potato chips have
you guys had him
yum oh and if uh marcus moves
you all get detention it seems like one
of you ought to give up the perm
but what about when we get separated at
church or six flags
okay okay hey guys guys guys wow you are
being
far too dramatic i mean don't you
realize how meaningless these little
teenage crushes are
come on only adult romances actually
mean anything
look the point is you should all just be
focused on your friendships
don't worry about all this petty dating
stuff okay you should all be down in
shots together
and doing dance is based on natural
disasters you know
leave all this other crap behind you
know otherwise you're just gonna be
stuck
in toledo going it alone look
you're gonna have your whole lives to
worry about dating okay
right now honestly you should probably
just be focused on masturbating you guys
all masturbate right
yeah show my hands real quick
oh no hey colin i was just thinking i'm
i'm so curious
did you happen to bang your mom last
night because i sure as hell didn't
no wait are you dating colin's mom isn't
that a conflict of interest
are you gonna start giving him extra
credit because you're doing his mom he's
not doing my mom
yeah because you wouldn't leave us alone
long enough to do it
okay i'm ready to do it okay
cool i can't i can't
damn it sarika
why won't no one staple my hand ah
victor there you are uh taking your
house this weekend big guy
what are you guys doing the great gatsby
yeah he ends up dead in a pool yeah oh
and um daisy killed myrtle oh
we're not there yet
you